We have just done all the hard work,
and now we can just sit back, relax and
let our beautiful model do all the work.
We're now up to the easy
part of our analysis,
what we're going to do is use our
historical model to predict the future.
The first thing we're going to do,
is output our model object that we're
going to use to then score our data set.
We don’t have to do this, but I just
think its best practice to output this,
so we don’t have to run the logistic and
the stepwise model over and over and
over again.
So they only thing we need to do
is bring in an output data tool,
connect it to the model object
that we want to output, and
then name this model and
save it off to a certain location.
So what I'm going to do is just
call it MOD for model object, OBJ.
And then I'll call it step at the end.
It's going to be saved off
as a YXDD type of format.
Let me run this model.
And then after this,
what I want to do is open up a blank
canvas and input that data set.
So I'm bringing the input data tool,
and input my model object.
What I'm also going to bring in is
the data set that I want to score.
So that's going to be our exact same
data set we read in to the build
the former model on, but not broken out
into estimation and validation samples.
I still need to make my
manipulations with the select tool
to make sure we have the correct
field types for our different values.
Now lastly, what I want to do is I
want to bring in that score tool.
The score tool needs no
real configuration, and
you can plug in your model object and
your data set into either side.
What we're going to do now is bring
in a browse tool and run this model.
If you look at the output
with the score tool and
the browse tool, we're able to see that
we have a predictive probability that
that individual will not respond, or
will respond to this marketing campaign.
As you can see,
these first individuals are very
likely to redeem a future offer.
While these individuals are not very
So let's think about this.
What we were just able to do is
determine the predictive probability to
redeem an offer for
every single individual.
Now that we've completed
the modeling and
scoring, it is time to report
our findings over to the boss.